Welcome to "Ear Biscuits".
The podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about sex for a long time.
I'm Link.
And I'm sex, I mean Rhett.
This week at The
Roundtable of Dim Lighting,
we are continuing on
with Sextember.
Tember!
It's actually the last
episode in Sextember
and instead of getting professionals
to give us solid,
evidence-based information,
now we're turning back to us.
Just the two guys who make this podcast.
We're also turning to you though.
We asked you if you had a
burning sex-related question.
I don't think that was
a gonorrhea reference.
Right, but well it could be.
Or a hilarious sex-related story.
We said we wanted to discuss
it on "Ear Biscuits".
Discust it.
We said you call us
at 1-888-EARPOD1.
1.
You could email us, we made an address
so it could be anonymous.
We're not gonna mention
any names today and Jenna,
if you're willing,
we want you to read the anonymous emails
so that we could have the
sense of it being a voicemail
even though it's just, we
all know it's just you.
Happy, happy to read
them for everyone yeah.
Are you gonna?
She's happy to read them.
Are you gonna do voices
or you going to do Jenna voice?
Jenna voice.
Okay.
Oh well, you could
change your mind.
We'll see.
I could change my mind.
Feel free to,
feel free to.
You can change your mind.
It's up to you.
We'll see when we get to it.
Do we need any preambles?
Of course just the warning
of this is more specific
and potentially explicit
sexy, sexy, sex conversation.
So if this isn't for you or any other ears
who may be in earshot.
Skip it or put some earbuds in.
I would say that I have
seen, and appreciated
a lot of the support that we've gotten
for going back into Sextember again
and talking about these things candidly.
I got very little if any
butt plug shaming thus far.
Just a couple of jokes
here and there maybe.
Oh yeah?
No shaming.
Yeah.
We've got a great herd of Mythical Beasts
that they're happy that we're
talking about sex again.
I do think that they're happy
that we brought in some
qualified professionals.
So today is our happy ending.
Exactly.
Of this series.
I, I'll tell you what I haven't
received, any butt plugs.
Well you know what?
Emily was supposed
to send us.
Well shipping.
I mean, she's gonna send them.
I mean it hasn't been that long you know?
Do I need to resort to
my own ordering devices?
Well first of all,
yes you could do your
own sex toy ordering.
I know that.
That is completely
up to you.
But I'm saying, I don't
want to be just inundated
with butt plugs.
If I'm gonna get them
from two different angles.
Well you can.
You know,
you kind of only want one angle at a time.
If you get too many butt plugs,
you can give them out for Christmas gifts.
I'm sure.
I never knew.
I'm sure your extended
family would appreciate that.
That the butt plug thing would
be such a cornerstone part
of this Sextember.
Well they make quite a stocking stuffer.
Is that what you call it?
Your stocking.
Yeah, yeah, what is that?
A turnip?
A Mario.
A Super Mario.
A Mario-shaped turnip.
Turnip, yeah, yeah.
All right, let's play one first.
I mean, maybe they didn't say their name.
I guess we can bleep it
but we're not gonna disguise voices.
Yeah yeah yeah.
All right, let's play
the first voice for them.
Hey Rhett and Link.
This is in regards to
your rated-R question
that you posed on Twitter just today.
Whatever today was.
Yeah.
My question to you is if you could
suck your own joint, would you?
Go.
I was asked this question at my old job
and they were very non-discriminating
about who they asked it too.
Pretty open about it
so I was wondering if you
guys would be that way too.
Have a great one.
So it was an interview question?
They asked it.
At this particular
place of work.
Indiscriminately asked
this question at his
former place of employment.
Would you suck your own joint?
I'm just imagining it's a Subway.
I don't know why, I don't.
I mean I just, I just was
imagining that question
being asked openly by Sandwich Artists.
While there's a line of
people waiting to order
the extra mayo.
Low fat mayo, don't do the low fat mayo.
Second of all, the term joint for
a penis?
I hadn't heard it.
Hadn't heard it, but I don't dislike it.
Yeah, I.
I knew immediately what
he was talking about.
Yeah, 'cause it was suck
your own was the first,
was the preamble to joint.
Yeah, yeah yeah right.
I don't know.
But I mean you could suck any joint.
People try to lick their own elbow.
Yeah, some people can successfully.
Well I don't know how to answer this
other than I've tried.
I mean, yeah.
I've tried too.
Who hasn't tried?
The people who haven't.
I mean, it kind of you know,
once you discover masturbation
it's pretty much like,
doesn't that seem like the next level?
Yeah it's like I can,
this hand is really well-equipped
to do a lot of great things.
It just dangles right down
there next to it.
But you're like,
what can this thing do?
I'm pointing at my mouth.
Not as flexible.
Not a lot if you
can't reach it.
I'm not as flexible as I used to be
but I'll just go on record
and say that I believe,
probably around age.
I was, at my sexual peak
and sexual limberness,
it probably like 16.
You know?
And I do remember, it's
funny how I feel like
I always end up saying
something really self-disclosing
and potentially embarrassing
really early in these episodes.
Yeah and then because you do,
I don't feel the need to say anything.
Okay, well.
Because I don't want it to seem like
I'm trying to outdo you
or compare myself to you
'cause I think it's important
that your sexual experience
is your own.
It's not about comparing it.
So I think sometimes.
No but when somebody asks you
if you've sucked your own
joint you've gotta answer.
I said that I've tried
and now you're about to say something else
but I just want to say.
Okay.
Maybe you're a little disappointed
that I haven't had as much
disclosure this month.
No no no no no.
As you have.
No, I wasn't saying it as opposed to you.
I was just saying it's just funny
how it just ends up happening
in these first questions.
I did make, how can I say?
I did at one point make
tongue to tip contact.
But it hurt really bad, like your back?
Your back was hurting.
But I was so uncomfortable
that, and I mean,
there was nothing else could happen.
It was just like they touched
in a moment of discovery
and beauty.
It's kind.
I'm sure it was not
beautiful to look at.
It's kind of like those angel babies
in the Sistine Chapel.
Like their fingertips
reaching out to each other.
No, that's God man.
That's the hand of God.
And I don't know in this
scenario if the tongue
or the dick is God.
Oh I thought it was,
I thought it was angel babies.
I think it's.
Aren't angel babies
reaching out too?
Well yeah, but one of the hands is God.
Oh, and the other one's a baby?
I don't know what the other hand is.
Yeah.
But one of them's
God's hand.
Yeah, well one of these
in this analogously
is our tongue.
If you could suck
your own.
And our collective penis.
If you could suck your own God's hand?
I'm sorry, I didn't mean
to get sacrilegious.
Yeah, don't do that.
I wasn't talking about your God.
Okay?
I was just talking about
an artistic representation.
I was talking about
somebody else's God.
Of the tension of almost touching it.
So anyway, tongue to tip
contact is the best I ever did.
Yeah, because you're bent over so far.
Especially with your back.
I was thinking that maybe
you had more success in this?
I remember my back was bent over so far
that like.
You're so flexible.
It was hurting so bad that it started,
you know it created a retreats
scenario for my member.
My joint.
I was, hold on.
As you might call it.
I was on my back.
Oh you were doing like a backwards roll?
I was on my back and I
was folding myself over.
Well listen, around, I
guess this was high school
when that Tool album came out
and when you opened it up.
Yep.
There was a picture
and I swear.
I don't know, I hope
this isn't just something
that I created in my head.
That you could move it
and it had that like,
it was two images with
the viewing angle thing
so it would have an
animation and it was a guy,
pleasuring himself with his.
Yeah, he was doing just this.
And he was shirtless.
Yeah.
And his back
was to the camera and he was like,
I just thought he was
waddling back and forth
and then I realized that no, no no.
This guy has achieved
something that requires
circus-level flexibility.
I just gotta say.
Can I try this?
And then it hurt too bad.
Right, if it was easy.
If my penis was my thumb,
I probably wouldn't have a
job you know what I'm saying?
I'd be like a baby.
I mean, I'm just gonna tell you right now.
If I could, I would.
Come on.
And if it was easy, I would
be doing it all the time.
If it was easy.
And so I'm glad
that it's hard.
If it was easy, everybody
would be doing it.
Right.
It doesn't apply to this,
any less than any other scenario
where you could use.
Speaking of God
there is a reason that
she didn't put the penis
on the thumb.
Because she knew that we
would all be you know,
sucking our thumbs all the time.
I mean I actually think
that's what determines
the length of your penis.
You know, so it can.
You know, if you think that like.
What?
Longer is better
and maybe you're self-conscious
about the length of it,
then you just say you know what?
It's a formula.
If it was too long,
you'd be in trouble.
Right.
If it was too long, you
wouldn't have a job.
Right.
I mean, I, yeah.
Is there anything else to say about this?
I think we've said quite a bit.
Let's get a story here.
I'm gonna click on this voicemail.
Hey, this is Morgan Wolmack.
I wanted to tell you
about a sex-related story
and I really don't care if
you keep it anonymous or not
because everybody knows
this at this point.
Everyone that I know anyway.
So when I was younger and
I was dating my boyfriend,
I skipped school and
went over to his house
and being the teenagers that we were,
we ended up in the bedroom.
Well his mom was not supposed
to come home from work
until like 5 p.m. but when we
were in the middle of, yeah,
I hear high heels clicking
on the wooden floor
outside of his door.
His mom slammed open his door
and started lecturing us, going off on us.
Both of us are buck-ass
naked in bed, freaking out.
I'm crying.
I had brought my iPod over
to my boyfriend's house,
it was set on shuffle.
While his mother
was lecturing us about
our horrible choices,
the song "Pour Some Sugar
on Me" by Def Leppard
started playing on the iPod.
Love it.
And it was across the room.
We could not turn it off.
So she lectured us to the soundtrack
of "Pour Some Sugar on Me".
My husband and I cut our
wedding cake to that song.
We're still together all
these years later, so.
That's my funny story.
And I'll never live it down.
Wow.
I still have friends
to this day call me when
that song's on the radio
just so I can hear it.
Yeah.
What?
You guys have a good day, bye.
Well we are now Morgan.
Morgan, Morgan, Morgan.
Listen, did Morgan say
that they got married?
Yes.
Like,
so there you go.
Yeah yeah yeah yeah.
Mom you were wrong.
Slip inside, walk this way.
Have sex in front of your mom hey hey!
Burning in the.
The one thing
that she didn't talk
about was what happened
when they were caught.
Because I've never been
caught having sex by anybody
and I don't really know
what the plan is here but I,
I think that if you're, okay.
Let's just go, I'm gonna
give you a scenario
on what I think you should do.
If you're having sex with
someone at their house,
like they're.
And they live with their parents
and their parents catch you
having sex with their child,
their daughter or son, whatever.
Having.
Yes, I'm tracking.
Then you have to stop having sex.
First of all, let's just
say you do not finish.
Once you're caught, you do not finish.
I think that's one rule but then I think,
you don't.
Yeah.
Don't run out.
I think you stand up
and introduce yourself.
I think you extend your hand.
If you made your bed, lie in it,
but you made your decision,
stand up and shake.
Sir, it's nice to meet you.
You know, you go and give
a nice, firm handshake.
Don't jump out the window,
don't go into the closet.
Because you are still
making your first impression
in that moment and it's like,
"Well you know what?
"He snuck in here, he
had sex with our daughter
"but he gave me a nice firm handshake."
You know and there's.
I wouldn't touch.
I wouldn't touch any parent.
Fist bump.
What about just a nice assertive wave.
Like point and snap.
Hey, just a little wave?
Don't touch, I don't wanna be touched.
Yeah, that's true.
I didn't think about that.
Yeah, no physical contact
with the.
I think a fist bump is okay.
With the parental figure.
Unless you've been fisting.
And at that point.
I would, hush yourself.
Then it could be a real trouble.
Hush.
Listen, I'd be in that closet before,
two clicks of the.
You go in the closet they, you can't.
It's an ostrich putting
its head in the sand.
You're still in the closet.
You just can't go
in the closet.
Thank you.
Yeah it just makes it awkward.
I think you gotta just
take it and be like.
I mean at least you
can then grab something
out of the closet, put it on and come out.
I do think putting maybe
putting a, some sort of like.
Whatever dress.
In fact if you got a sheet.
Quickly apply it like a toga
and then you just look like
a history buff.
Oh we were,
you know we were actually
doing our Greek homework.
Yeah that's right, this is role play.
Yeah it is.
Mm-hmm.
We were in the bath.
The Roman bath.
There's no penetration.
What do you mean there's no penetration
in the Roman bath?
No no I'm saying, I'm going along with it.
Oh.
I'm saying you gotta say,
you gotta tell the parents
there's no penetration.
As I've established I've
been seen through a window
by hikers.
But I've never been
caught by someone I knew,
I've almost been caught by
a child who just came in.
You gotta make sure that door is locked.
Well put yourself in the shoes of a parent
and let's say you come home and you find
one of your children having lovey time
with a significant other.
Yeah.
What are you going to do
in that moment?
What would you do?
I would not,
well I'd try not to burst into doors
and catch people, kids doing anything.
True.
So if.
But let's say accidentally, you knocked,
they didn't hear you.
I would immediately.
I would immediately leave.
All right.
Right.
And I would say,
"Let's discuss this later."
Discuss this later.
That's the funny part of the story.
Yeah I mean.
Is that,
you gotta.
Obviously they're
probably not gonna finish
after they've been caught.
Mission accomplished, you stopped them
from having sex, whatever.
You close the door and then you just go
and sit in the living room and just wait.
I would take a jog probably.
Well.
Yeah.
I would like.
But you don't lecture them
in the moment.
I'd probably,
I do have a punching bag in my garage
that Christy got years ago.
When was the last time
you punched that thing?
I've never punched it.
But I think this would
be the perfect occasion.
Yeah.
So that's where
I would be.
I would be out there just
punching the daylights
out of that thing.
Okay.
And just trying
to figure out how I'm gonna
keep my cool afterward.
Well also.
It's a natural process,
what was happening.
You hope that it's happening
in a way that is responsible.
Yeah.
And I think that's
the way you want to have the conversation.
Because it sounds like in this scenario,
maybe Morgan's parents didn't know
that she was having sex
yet or whatever, you know.
Yeah.
But if you're like,
oh my kids are sexually active,
in a relationship or whatever
and you know that they're having sex,
then catching them
having sex is kind of a,
is different than this
being your you know,
realization that your kids are having sex.
Right.
It's so difficult to decide
to start talking openly about sex.
Especially with your first child.
You know, if you have multiple children.
Because it, unless you're
in a really open household
where you just discuss all these things
and you make sex references all the time,
even before your kid can understand
what they're talking about.
So they never can remember a moment
when you weren't making some
sort of sexual reference.
Just kind of like oh I remember watching
this sitcom for years
and then I got to an age
where I realized that they've
been making sexual references
the whole time.
That's kind of a nice way
to just kind of make it part
of what the, the communication
climate in the home.
But practically speaking,
for a lot of people, including me.
That never happened.
So it's like now that my kids are,
I have older kids and younger kids,
there was a different dynamic of you know,
you're referencing things
and we're making a decision
to kind of like, the fact that sex exists
and it is, and they have
an opportunity to do it.
It's like we might as well.
It's counterproductive
to never speak of it
and then the younger siblings,
they just kind of get,
they kind of absorb it in
a way that inoculates you,
in a good way to it being
something we can never talk about,
it's a taboo.
But with that first child at least,
I'm oversimplifying here.
You have to make this decision
and it's hard to not do it too late.
You know?
And I think it's a little bit,
a little bit goes a long way
and it's better to start a
little early than too late.
It helps when your kids are
begging you to tell them which
is what happened with Locke.
Yeah.
Which we talked about
last it but yeah, Morgan,
sounds like it all worked out for you.
Yeah, congrats on the marriage.
Jenna, let's get to an anonymous email.
Would you like a question or story first?
Let's go question.
Okay.
Doesn't like sex, how can I spice it up?
Hello, long time fan, first time emailer.
Okay, I have a sex-related
question that might be TMI.
Great.
I've been with my husband
for seven whole years and
while I hate to admit it,
our sex life is boring, sad, predictable.
I even once told him to please
don't love me in the bedroom.
Do you guys have suggestions
how to spice it up
or just how to initiate that
uncomfortable conversation?
P.S., we're both huge fans.
All the best, I ask my
husband to love me everywhere
but the bedroom.
Please don't love me in the bedroom is.
First, stop saying that.
Yeah.
Step one.
I guess what they're
getting at is you know,
foreplay starts out of the bedroom.
That's not what I heard.
What did you hear?
They want to have sex somewhere else,
like not in the bedroom?
No I heard that they are not having
a very active sex life.
Well I heard that too.
For whatever reason.
And, but the thing is.
Seven years.
Is that it sounds like
there is a desire to have
a more active sex life
and maybe they're both on
team let's have more sex
and let's have a more satisfying sex life.
I think one of the things that we learned
in talking to the Dr. Emilys,
Doctors Emily.
Right.
That's when you say Attorneys General,
that's how you say it.
Right.
You know the Doctors Emily is that
it's, and I have a tendency to do this.
I have a tendency to
normalize my situation
and my behavior and then sort of say
that this is the way that it
should be for other people
and as I get older, I am
learning to do that less and less
and one of the things
that they both hinted at
was this idea
there's not a normal
amount of sex or whatever.
But if you are both on
team let's have more sex,
that's a good start right?
Because that's a place that you're like,
oh we're not as satisfied
as we would like to be.
So, because you've gotta
communicate it to some point
where you can get on the same page
and know what the next step is
and then if you're on that page,
then okay well what does that look like?
How do you spice it up,
how do you have more sex?
How do you have love
me in the bedroom time?
That's kind of what I was hearing there.
I, yeah.
I think the best advice here is you know,
get the "Come as You Are"
book, read it together.
Discuss it.
I mean there's even a
workbook if you're into that.
I just think that that will go a long way.
As I was reading it in preparation
for our last conversation
Christy reread it.
She had already read it
years ago and I never read it
because as with a lot of books,
she's really into the
nonfiction, self help,
reference material-type stuff
of whatever she's into at the time.
And she'll always say, "I
want you to read this."
And you know what?
I never do it.
I just say, "Just tell me about it."
Just tell me about it.
Give me the blink version.
Just give me the active sex version of it.
Yeah yeah yeah, yeah.
Like you read it, now just show me.
Yeah, what do you want me to do?
Visual aids, welcome.
Yeah.
Right?
But reading it separately
but then talking about it
together was really beneficial
and it, it even gets you more horny.
Giving yourself a structure
and especially when that
is specifically designed
to talk about sex
and to talk about things.
Right.
That maybe you're not informed about
from a professional
standpoint, I completely agree.
That's a great book but
there's also other books
and I'm sure there might even be books
that I don't know about
that are designed for,
people in this exact situation.
Just Google, "Book for couple
that wants to have more sex."
Whatever, in fact I think that Emily has,
Emily Morris, Dr. Emily
Morris has a book about
200 things you can do tonight right?
Yeah and then.
Oh that's a lot
in one night.
Yeah and then Dr. Nagoski is coming out
with a new book as well.
Right.
About keeping things fun
for longterm relationships.
Yeah it's a common thing.
There's so many resources
out there, yeah.
So don't feel weird about it
but just discuss it.
And make it into a little happy project.
Yeah play "Pour Some Sugar on Me".
See what happens when you
do that in the bedroom.
Or just pour some sugar on each other?
And you know what?
I've never done that.
See what happens.
Straight sugar.
Straight sugar, all right.
Voicemail.
Hi Rhett and Link, love you guys so much.
My name's Sarah.
I am just curious,
I was such a fan of
"Sex Biscuits" last year
and I know Rhett and
Link, both of you guys
but I feel like I heard
it more from Rhett,
address the issue of
vibrators in the bedroom
and I am a young woman
and I would love to use one in the bedroom
and I'm just curious how you think a woman
should approach that
subject with their man?
How to introduce that?
You know?
I do know.
I feel like some men
might be opposed to it.
Right.
But I think a woman
might very much enjoy it,
as I would too.
But, yeah.
Thank you so much if you answer this.
Love you guys, have a great day.
All right,
we are gonna answer it.
Thank you Sarah.
So she's gonna love us.
You know what?
I actually think that, my
guess is that many fewer men
than you would think are actually,
like threatened by a vibrator.
I think that most guys
are turned on by it.
Again, I'm speaking for
most people at this point
and maybe I'm making a mistake here.
I'm just saying that as
somebody who likes to think
that I can get the job done
and I'm proud of myself
in that area.
I don't see a vibrator as a threat.
I see as just a little
sexy twist you know?
And also you know, I'm
into modern technology.
Yeah.
You know I mean,
the fact that we live, what
a time to be alive you know?
That these things can exist.
And sometimes they can
really just get the job done.
I think using a vibrator on your own
can be a very viable way to
figure out what works for you.
And then if that's why you
want to bring it in there
because it's like, hey this can help us.
This can help me when
we're together, you know?
And then your partner can learn from it.
I mean, it's a great thing.
I'm a fan of the vibrator
being a part of the excursion.
Oh yeah.
Because it just helps.
You know?
And you can use them at the same time.
You can use a vibrator which,
or your partner, she can use a vibrator
and then you're still penetrating.
So it's a two for one.
And if you're worried about.
It's a two for one.
If you're worried about the,
first of all, I just
think the simplest way
is just to be like, hey ask the question.
How would you feel about it?
And I think you might be
surprised by the answer.
Be like, I think that's hot
is what I think most guys would say
but if you're worried about that.
Here's one way you could do it.
Take a, I'm holding a giant vibrator.
Take a vibrator, take a toothbrush.
Cut the head off of the toothbrush.
Glue the toothbrush part to the vibrator
and then just start using
it as a toothbrush for,
I'd say, four to six weeks.
And he'll be like,
"That's one hell of a
vibrating toothbrush."
You be like, "Yeah it's a new thing.
"New tech from Colgate."
I don't know, just throw a brand in these.
It makes it seem legitimate.
Oral B.
And you hold it like it's
gonna be different than the.
Oral D.
And it's gonna be different
than those ones.
But then he'll, it's like when
you're trying to get a dog
to be accustomed to the crate
that they're eventually gonna be in.
Yep.
First thing you do
is you just set it in the room.
And then they're like, "Okay,
this thing's not a threat.
"Maybe I'll get in there one day."
You've gotta slowly get a man,
you have to treat a man
like an animal sometimes.
Yep.
And you just,
you let him know this
thing's not a threat.
That giant pink toothbrush
that she's been enjoying
for the past six weeks,
it's not a threat.
Next thing you know, she's got
it in the bed and he's like,
"Oh, brushing your teeth early?"
And no and then you just demonstrate
what else you can do with it
and I think he'll go along with it.
Yeah, if it's not about the threat
but it's just about this
feels weird, maybe you're,
maybe there's a grounded
version of that advice
that actually works.
There's truth in what you're saying.
You find a way to ease into it.
I don't know exactly what that is but,
because for us, we talked about last year.
We both, you and I went and
bought the same vibrator.
No we both bought the
same model of vibrator.
The Green Worm.
But we each had our own.
We didn't have to loan it out.
No, you shouldn't do that.
You don't share it.
Have a signup sheet.
And then remember I
put the mask on Christy
and then I broke it out
and just started poking her
around different places.
Come up with a different verb man.
I surprised her with it.
In different, not just down there but.
Yeah, under the arm.
It just was like,
it was just a fun little playful thing
but I did spring it on her
and I don't quite recommend
that but it was my idea
and it was just like hey I got.
And I did say I got something.
Yeah, just one idea.
I'm trying to develop
some freaking advice here.
Oh.
I'm trying
to land on something.
Take a playful approach
in a neutral setting
where you can have a conversation about it
and you can make it a little sexy.
Just like hey I had this idea, what if,
what if we used a vibrator
next time we have sex?
Just think about it.
Just give it, just give him a beat.
Just logging it.
Just think about it.
It's just an idea.
Something, just something to
make more fun for both of us.
Let's make more fun together.
You ever touched yourself with a vibrator?
Yeah.
It doesn't quite do, it's a little.
No.
It can be a
little overwhelming
but at times, you know?
And it's nice to have sex
and have your partner control the vibrator
and then it's like,
there's a communication
about like, what's too much?
If there's a couple of
things going on at once
and then you, all right,
let's reduce it to one thing at once
and then the other thing.
And you get to a point where it's like,
'cause talking about, I
think it was mentioned
over the last two episodes.
Well masturbating in
front of your partner.
A mutual masturbation sesh.
That seems,
I mean when you just say
it, that seems so weird
but then.
Really?
It does, as an idea.
As an abstract idea it's like,
"We're gonna walk in this room
"and then we're gonna
each pleasure ourselves
"while we watch each other."
It's like, but practically speaking
it's something that can just
find its way into happening.
And then you find like oh
this is just another way
that we can play together,
even though we're playing with ourselves.
So it's not all this stark,
let's decide to do this.
It's more of like let's
have an attitude of play
and an openness to know what the,
what are the, what are the
toys that we can use here?
What are the things we can try?
And you just kind of keep it open ended
and just make it an adventure
and just see what happens
and try certain things.
Some things don't work,
you can kind of pull back.
You can just take the
batteries right out of it.
And sometimes you'll surprise yourself.
When you're in the heat of passion,
the things that you say
and the things that you do,
it's like that's part of the fun of it
is just like wow, there's,
I didn't even know I
had this in me you know?
There's like a release of
not just sexual tension
but also personality.
Release your personality in the bedroom.
Yeah.
Here's a story.
So I have an embarrassing
sex-related story.
It was actually from
when I lost my virginity.
Now to most people this
might sound like a dream
but it in fact was not.
I lost my virginity in a threesome.
What?
Yes.
A threesome.
Now, what made it so bad?
Let me tell you,
I really didn't know
what to with my hands.
So while the two lovely
people that I was also with
were kind of going at it, I
was kind of sitting there.
I just started doing the chacha
because I had no clue what else
to do and they looked at me.
I was very embarrassed to the
point where things went soft.
So, yeah that's my sex, my
sexy sexy, embarrassing story.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
I had.
What is?
What does the cha cha actually look like?
Is it like this?
No.
It's footsteps.
Sounds like he was standing up and.
He was standing up.
Yeah it's like a little.
Like forward and backward.
Yeah forward and back kind of step.
Wow, thanks for sharing.
But I do believe virginity was lost,
I don't believe.
That virginity
to the cha cha.
I don't personally believe
in the loss of virginity.
I don't think there is a,
we talked about this.
That's true.
I don't believe
that you have something
that you're losing.
Sex was had.
For the first time.
For the first time
during a threesome.
Wow.
That's bold.
Yeah that's bold.
I mean you can again,
in the heat of passion
you can find yourself in
interesting situations
and it's nice to be able to
access some sort of game plan.
The cha cha.
Call it your
personal cha cha.
And it can't be that,
can't be the awkward cha cha.
I mean, I've never come anywhere close
to having a threesome you know?
As we firmly established.
I've only had sex with one person
and that's Christy.
Firmly.
I don't, you know it's, man.
Yeah I wouldn't know exactly.
I'm not.
Get in where you fit in
but that's sometimes that's not obvious.
Now my assumption here is that the people
who were the other two
members of the threesome
probably did not realize that this person
had never had sex before.
I'm not gonna give advice,
much advice about threesomes
because I don't have any experience
but it just feels to me like it would be
a good guideline to be like,
um, maybe that's not the best way
for someone to have sex for the first time
in the context of a threesome.
That's just, you know.
Especially if you're not
a good multitasker.
That's my uniformed opinion.
It feels like chapter two at the earliest.
Yeah, talk about jumping
in at the deep end.
Wow, that's.
You know what?
I mean and again,
a little sense of humor goes a long way.
I think if you're doing the cha cha
and they're kind of like, laughing.
It's just you just try and own it.
Well you just try and own it.
Well I have to assume
that that, them looking
at him doing the cha cha
was the thing that they
were like oh do you wanna?
Would you like to be a part?
Do you want us to dance as well
or would you like to do what we're doing?
And that was probably what
proceeded to the moment.
Here's another question.
Hey Rhett and Link.
This is Anonymous from Texas.
So I have this question
after listening to your
sexpisode that you just had
and coming from a similar
background as y'all
with the purity culture,
Evangelical upbringing,
I would be curious to hear an expert talk.
Perhaps somebody that might know
in embarrassment around stamina,
lasting long and whatnot.
So short of taking the little blue pill,
I'm curious if y'all
have experience with this
or if you have any experts you
know that could talk on this.
Be blessed.
Any experts in the room?
Nope, but we can talk about stamina.
I mean stamina is really built up
as this thing of like, and I do feel this.
Culturally, not in my specific bedroom.
But culturally this pressure
to you know, to go long
and strong and when something
can be as fun as sex,
it's like yeah you wanna,
you don't want it to be every
time be over within a flash.
Yeah.
You wanna be able
to draw out the experience and but,
even speaking specifically about like,
the old in and out.
Like you get to the actual specific,
the in and out of sex
and at a certain point,
you'd like for that particular action
to be, to go on for awhile.
But that's difficult to do.
The thrusting, the thrusting.
The thrusting.
The old cha cha.
Is difficult to maintain.
I mean, in my experience.
You know, so you find
yourself mixing things up.
It's like all right, I'm gonna
do that for a little while
and then I'm gonna do something different.
So you know, we're still very much engaged
but it's like, all right.
So you switch gears but also,
you switch practices right?
Yeah, for sure.
And you can go back and forth.
So that's one thing.
Now when I started my anxiety medication,
I read about with onboarding
of a medication like that
that you could have sexual
side effects and that they,
at a certain point, when
your medication leveled out,
it, that would level out too.
And I did experience that.
So at first it was.
Well what?
Yeah it was like, I'm,
everything's taking longer.
It's taking longer for
me to get an erection
and then it's taking
longer to reach climax.
And there were a few times
that I did find myself
uncharacteristically in my
head about well, hold on?
Is this gonna, am I gonna
be able to pull this off?
Am I gonna be able to
complete the task here?
And yeah that, I could
see how that would lead
to a downward spiral and just,
everything would fizzle out.
But I also experienced this middle ground
where I was able to go longer
and so we had a different experience.
Well actually this
is interesting.
Which was good.
That this guy mentions the blue pill,
Viagra or Cialis or whatever.
And now,
just to finish my trajectory.
It did get to a point, I
don't know how long it took
that it was kind of like,
I'm back to how I was
before I was on the medication.
I don't feel like.
And that's not necessarily.
It was actually an effect.
Okay, what I have heard from
multiple sources is that,
okay, so one of the
reasons that we have this,
this obsession with stamina
is that a lot of us get our
ideas about sex from porn
and obviously the average dude in a porn
can sit there and thrust
with multiple women
in multiple holes for like an hour
and that is not what,
and we don't use the term
normal but I'm gonna say,
that is not normal for me.
But what I have been told
is that most of these guys doing porn
and correct me if I'm wrong
if you know the ins and outs
of this is that these guys are mostly
all on SSRIs and Viagra or Cialis.
Is one of the ways that
they're able to maintain that
'cause I don't necessarily
think it's always the case that,
first of all I don't think it's bad.
I think that, I think that
this is a positive side effects
of SSRIs is in my opinion,
If it makes you last longer.
As long as it doesn't.
As long as you don't,
you don't lose the erection.
Right, yeah it was a good experience.
It kind of opened up, yeah,
a different, different avenue.
And I'm not prescribing this,
I'm just saying that this
is an interesting tidbit
of like, if you combine the SSRI
which you shouldn't just take SSRIs
for reasons other than to
treat clinical depression,
a diagnosed disorder from a psychiatrist
but it's an interesting thing
that they're doing both of
those things in some cases
where they're giving
themselves the ability
to go for a long time
without losing the erection
because of the Cialis or the Viagra
and maybe they're not just supertroopers
who can go for an hour
but maybe there's some
medical assistance there.
Two data points from me.
I talked to my dad about this
on "Dispatches From Myrtle Beach".
You know, came up in conversation
because I was asking him.
He said he's used it and I was like,
"Yeah, but why don't you
talk about the erection?
"It lasts for like 12 hours."
He was like.
It's four hours.
Is what the ad says.
If your erection lasts
for more than four hours
call a doctor.
So he's, he had some success with it.
Success.
Oh I've never used it
but I definitely don't think
that there is any shame
in using it and I think that,
when I'm talking about
some sort of ED assistance kind of thing.
Right.
But definitely,
if it, the moment that I'm like,
I feel like I need some,
I'm making the call.
You can do it online.
There's no shame in that
game, it's like again,
just like, what a time to be alive.
I've met a friend for lunch.
He was a friend of a friend
and we were kind of
getting to know each other.
You actually don't know this
person and middle-aged guy
and we were talking about vacation,
we were talking about
vacation sex or something
and he was like, hey I'll give you a.
He's older than us.
I think he's probably, he
was in his 50s and he said,
"You know what?
"We'll schedule a day and
I'll take one of the pills
"and then we'll just."
Just, he was talking about
it like it was miraculous.
Like he could just go and
go and go and it was like,
so he was giving me the inside scoop.
He was like hey.
My only fear about this,
because it is a documented,
it is documented that for some men,
using that kind of assistance
when you're already healthy
and you actually don't need it
in order to have successful sex
or to maintain an erection
can do something psychological
where you become dependent on it.
I'm sure plenty of people use it
in the way that this guy's
describing but if it's just like,
oh now do I need?
I would be worried and
again it is documented
that for some men,
they feel like they become reliant on it
in order to get it up and keep it up.
So I've just thought to myself,
because I've thought about
this exact same thing
because I've heard multiple
people talk about this.
Like hey, you're doing.
It's anniversary weekend
and you've got a hotel or whatever.
Bring some Cialis along with
you because one of them,
I don't know.
One of them is like, hey take it now
and you'll be ready in 30 minutes
and one of them is take it
and you'll be ready all day.
I can't remember which one is which
so do you own research but
the one that's more acute,
I've thought about that
but the thing that's kept
me from it is this fear
that oh it'll be so good
that then I'm gonna feel like
I'm gonna become reliant on it
and then you can have
this psychological effect
where you actually do have trouble
because it's so mental.
I mean maintaining an erection
is such a mental thing.
Which again.
Proceed with caution.
Yeah and also you know,
maintaining the stamina
can be a mental thing.
So one thing in addition
to changing it up,
like oh that feels too good, change it up.
You can also just think
about Richard Nixon you know?
You just picture.
Tricky Dick.
You just picture someone
that you're not attracted to.
In my case that would be Richard Nixon.
Richard Nixon represents like,
there's nothing about Richard
Nixon that I'm attracted to.
I don't want my wife to know that hey,
you're having a great time,
I'm thinking about former
President Richard Nixon
but hey, whatever it takes to keep going.
Well, I would just be afraid
to find myself start
to have a Nixon fetish.
You don't want to associate
your wife with Richard Nixon?
It hasn't happened so far with me.
All right, let's hear another story here.
Hi Rhett and Link.
I'm gonna keep my name out of this
because it's pretty embarrassing
but I have a pretty
weird sex-related story.
My ex that I was dating,
unfortunately for about three years.
One time we had just
finished sorting the mail
and we were cuddling
and he decided that it would
be funny to scoot up on the bed
and pee directly on my face.
I genuinely was so surprised in the moment
and had absolutely no clue
what was going on but yeah,
we broke up a couple months after that.
So, unfortunately,
shouldn't have been with him
that long in the first place.
But you know, hindsight is 20/20.
Anyways, super excited for Sextember.
Love you guys, bye.
What the flying hell?
I'm sorry this happened to you.
I mean consent is paramount.
I don't, besides that.
I'm just, it makes me angry
and I don't want to talk about this one.
Besides that, it makes you angry?
I mean I don't, besides saying that
I have nothing else to say.
I mean obviously this was a big nono
only because of the fact that she,
because the consent thing.
But let's assume, let's
talk about peeing on people.
While we're here in the subject matter.
I mean, because I want to
talk about that a little bit.
I'll let you do that if you want to
but it's, you don't have to.
Yeah, I don't have any
experience with this.
This isn't something that
I have, I'm just saying.
Let's say that this situation was.
We're talking about a golden shower here.
I was, if the story.
It does have a name.
If the story was.
I guess some people
are into it and they consent to it.
Well you call it, but you don't.
Okay, you said it was
some people are into it.
That sounded a little kink shamey to me.
Some people are into everything.
Yeah so yeah.
I made it about consent.
Yeah well, but I want to talk
about this in general though
because if this isn't something
that has presented it.
Now again, we've established
before that my wife squirts.
I established that on a previous episode
and we know that at least
some of what's happening
during a squirt, it is urine.
There's other stuff in there too.
It's complex,
not completely that well understood
but I guess in that sense,
I have been peed on in some regard
but it doesn't feel
like that in the moment.
It isn't like hey.
Right.
"Pee on me, because I
want you to pee on me."
Now, I'm not,
if that's what you want,
that's what you want.
If that's what you want,
you gotta be on the same page
and if you are, go for it.
Go for it.
But I don't see this being something that
I'm gonna request that
I'm gonna get from Jessie
for me to pee into her face.
But you know what?
If she asks me to, I'd be like,
"All right, this feels weird
"and but if you want me to try it."
The thing is is I feel like
I might even be a little,
I might get too gunshy in that situation.
Sometimes it takes a lot.
I can be next to somebody at an airport
and there's not a divider
between the two urinals
and I have trouble just letting it go.
You know what I'm saying?
I get a little stage fright.
I think the psychology of this
is part of the appeal for
those who are into it you know?
So being able to just let loose.
You know?
Obviously Link really wants to move on
and now I'm getting pleasure
in not letting him move on.
Jenna.
Read an email.
Okay, just moving on.
But I agree consent, consent yeah yeah.
That's a shitty person.
For real.
Yeah, yep.
But yeah, if people like the peeing thing.
Definitely go for it, have fun.
But that's not cool.
Okay, got a story.
Here's a good one.
The person did put
their name in the email.
Well let's just leave it off.
We'll leave it anonymous okay.
"Dear Messers Rhett and Link,
"I humbly submit the following
story for Sextember 2022.
"It's the story of my
first time with a girl.
"She and I met at my college dorm.
"Our chemistry was strong,
"so strong that we decided
to take it to my dorm room.
"We're making out, it's
getting hot and heavy.
"You know the Meat Loaf song,
"'Paradise by the Dashboard Light?'
"Yep, like that."
I don't like that song.
But yeah, okay.
It was like that apparently, yeah.
"As I'm about to sheath
my penis in a condom."
Good.
"Suddenly my dorm's
"fire alarm goes off."
Bad.
"It was like the stop right there part
"of the aforementioned song.
"We both panic, grabbing
whatever clothes were on hand.
"We followed the rest of my
entire college dorm outside
"into the cold, pouring
rain of early March.
"We were both miserable for a minute
"but then burst out laughing.
"We've been together for 13 years
"and we got married in April of 2020.
"Thanks for listening."
Congratulations, another success story.
Yeah.
I wonder if
he unsheathed it first.
Okay, I feel bad about giving this advice.
But like 99% of all college
dorm room fire alarms are fake.
You know what I'm saying?
Don't.
I don't want, listen.
I don't want you to
get burned up in a fire
and if I'm sorry if it happens to you
but I'm just gonna go ahead
and tell you right now.
Most of the time there's just some
just pulling the fire alarm for a prank.
Sure, sure take that risk.
No I'm just saying
if it were me.
It's on you Rhett.
I'm not giving the advice.
I'm just saying if it were me.
First of all, I'm glad
that it ended in success
and now you're married
so it worked for you.
But I'm just saying, put
me in that situation,
I'm in a college dorm.
Not now, not 44-year-old Rhett
but back in the day Rhett
and I'm sheathing it
up and I'm ready to go
and then the alarm goes off.
I think I'm gonna be like hey listen,
statistically speaking
this is probably not a real thing.
Let's not stay out in the cold.
Let's stay here and screw.
That's probably how I would've handled it.
Let's make it quick, this is exciting.
We can actually do both at the same time.
We could evacuate and.
What do you mean by evacuate?
Evacuate.
Evacuate is like a term
for pooping.
Oh.
Which again.
Well just like.
No judgment.
Ejaculate.
If that's what you wanna do.
We can evacuate
and ejaculate.
If the consent is involved
and you want someone to poop on you.
All right.
During a fire alarm.
Let's get another voicemail.
Then that is your right.
Hey Rhett and Link.
Big fan, Shaun here.
Just curious,
have you guys ever dealt
with post-nut clarity?
Because that's rough, it's a rough ride.
Just immediately afterwards
when you're done doing your thing.
You just sit, singularity and
just kind of think about life.
So yeah, just kind of curious on that.
Kind of curious on how
your post-nut clarity
has changed over the years.
So yeah, thanks guys.
Love what you do, peace.
Post-nut clarity is not something
that I've ever heard named but my,
the only way.
Really?
I relate to it in that like,
I guess it's akin to when you ejaculate,
then it's just like, there's the trope
of I've totally lost interest.
Or it's over.
I can just roll over and
go to sleep or whatever.
No no this is
a well-established phenomenon.
It's like going off a cliff.
But being sharper mentally?
No.
I can definitely relate
to jerking off and then being really,
feeling really guilty about it.
At a young age in
the environment I grew up in.
I think it's more.
What I've always understood
this concept to be is just like,
I was thinking with my other head
and now I'm thinking once
again with my brain head
and usually, you hear this
in the context of like,
oh I was you know,
having sex with somebody
that I didn't really want to
or I was being driven by my sexual energy
in a way that then, once it was released
I was like how the hell did I get myself
in this situation?
Like regret.
Yeah and then in the context of porn,
if you can picture the quintessential teen
who's gone down a rabbit
hole into some just you know,
you're watching 80 Russian elderly ladies
have an orgy or something.
You're really way down
the rabbit hole of porn.
Okay.
And then you think to yourself,
"Why am I watching this and
how have I got to this point?"
Right after you masturbate.
Okay.
That's how
I've heard about it in.
But I remember this as a teen.
Especially as a teen in purity culture
who thought that masturbation was wrong.
And so then you would be like.
Right.
"Oh man, now I see how wrong this is
"and I'm praying about
"being forgiven."
Right it sucked.
It was horrible.
So that version of clarity
which is horrible.
But this isn't much
of a phenomenon as a
middle-aged man at this point.
So I don't think I've been like harnessing
my post-nut clarity.
I think I've just been going to sleep.
I mean I'm definitely gonna tell Christy
that like sex makes me
smarter for a limited time.
Yep, right.
So it's like,
that's something I haven't sold
too much.
It's hard to talk yourself
into making longterm financial decisions
right after you have sex
but apparently that would be a good idea.
Let's hear this story.
Hey Rhett and Link,
I had an encounter with a
lovely woman I recently met
and we hit it off great, had a few dates
and we eventually ended up at my place
and basically the mail was gonna be sorted
and she paused and looked at me
and specifically asked to
not have her socks taken off
at any point.
I obviously agreed and
whatever but I mean,
what's the deal with socks
staying on during sexytime?
Jenna, you're having a reaction to this.
I am.
From a, my viewpoint of it is is that she,
perhaps hasn't had a pedicure in awhile
or there's like an ingrown toenail
that she's embarrassed about.
I don't see it as like.
Yeah.
There's some practical reason that it.
There's a practical reason
she wanted to keep her.
It's cold.
Or just, or her feet get extremely cold
and she doesn't want to shock him
with her freezing feet.
Yeah.
And the fact
that she said it upfront,
I don't see a big deal
with the socks thing,
at all.
No.
I find it kind of sexy.
I mean I find it sexy when
a woman leaves her shoes on
first of all.
Knocking the boots.
Because then it feels
like an athletic event.
It fells like we may be
being scored by judges.
You know what I'm saying?
Like if you got on
shoes and again, I mean,
I think the sexiest thing and
this is probably like some,
unresolved misogyny is I
love women in high heels.
I'm working through that.
But you know, there's.
Are you?
There's the classic.
You sitting around
working on?
Your view of high heels?
I'm trying to like
naked ladies in high heels less
with every day that passes.
But it is, is it not a sexy
thing and do you find it?
Is a sexy thing
when a naked lady in high heels?
I just love socks man.
I love stockings.
But I do believe that.
For me it's not
about the heels.
It's about the fabric up the calf.
But I also think maybe
I have a disposition,
a bias towards this because my wife is 5'3
and I'm 6'7.
Yeah.
So heels actually, you know what?
In my case, women wearing
heels is all about equity.
It's all about us being
closer to the same height.
To your height.
Closer.
Why don't you
just bend over more?
You see, I just made it
a very progressive thing
but here's the thing.
I kind of think that maybe
wearing like some Air Jordans
or something.
Wearing some cross trainers,
wearing something that
makes you feel athletic.
Listen, if there is a fire alarm,
we'll be the first ones out there.
Both of you put those
kinds of shoes on and maybe
a headband and wristbands.
I like that.
Gloves even.
Things that make you feel
like you're going to work.
Doing something that matters.
Anything that makes it different
can be something that
can make it exciting.
A trucker hat.
Yeah and especially if you're
getting to know your partner
and they, you gotta acknowledge
that this is a point
of putting themselves out there.
There's a risk involved in saying,
"Hey, I don't wanna,
don't take my socks off."
Be like, "You know what?
"I love your socks and I'm so glad
"you don't want to take them off."
I got more socks, we can double them up.
You wanna put even, can
I keep my socks on too?
Yeah.
It's like,
everything's an opportunity
to just get hornier
you know?
You ever worn
just a belt?
Yeah, no.
Yeah, well I haven't either but it just,
it struck me as that might be cool.
Hey, let's just wear belts.
We just have belts on and nothing else.
Yeah.
I mean, why not right?
How do you have the best sex?
Belt.
Like a utility belt?
It's got all.
A utility belt's got all
the little vibrators
and stuff in there.
Oh yeah.
Pew pew pew pew pew.
You can be like Btman up in there.
So yeah, I mean you want to
turn everything into a turn on
and when somebody shares more
of themself, that's a turn on.
Double down on it.
Don't question somebody's,
somebody's request
if it can be easily accommodated.
I mean you don't want
to put up any barriers,
you know what I'm saying?
Jenna do you have another email?
Yes, this story I have thoughts on.
Here it goes.
"Are you ready for a pathetic story?
"My first boyfriend and I had breakup sex.
"He lasted 30 wriggly seconds."
Wriggly.
"Then he got up, farted
"and asked if he could
have my Diablo II account
"since I didn't like playing it anyway.
"I said no, then he left
"and we never saw each other again.
"Believe in fairytales people."
Well were all three of
these things related?
I mean maybe they're just all,
it all just coincided.
Short, amount of sex, a
fart that was unanticipated
and oh while I'm thinking
about it, Diablo II.
You know, we are grouping
these things together
at least in the context of the story
as if they are related.
So maybe we just go with that.
Yeah, I just don't know
about tying up loose ends.
Ending a sentence in an exclamation point
but it's a fart after sex.
I just.
That's weird man.
I mean it's a little flagrant.
It's a little flagrant you know?
Flagrant foul, don't bring
farts into the bedroom
if you can help it.
Or, unless you're into it.
Unless it's asked for.
Yeah, yeah.
What are your thoughts?
Well maybe, maybe,
I think he probably should've asked
about the Diablo II account
before the sex and farting
or if he was asking about it after,
I think he should've
put in a bit more effort
into the sex part if he was
going to ask this big thing.
Right.
Yeah, read the room man.
Of his ex partner.
Yeah, read the room.
Right.
But yeah, I think if that was my ex
that I was having breakup sex
with and that happened to me,
I would think the appropriate
response would be well,
at least your farts
last longer than you do.
Oh.
And then skipping,
like that is so.
Dang.
That's hard to remember
though in the moment.
That was good.
In the moment you're.
If that happens to you.
In the moment
you're probably.
Damn.
I think in the moment
I'd just be kind of like,
okay?
It could be a text later.
A text later, no, no.
Breakup text.
Immediately blocked and
I'm like you know what?
I wanna completely forget.
At least your farts
last longer than you do.
This entire.
I mean the whole not lasting a long time,
for breakup sex, that's not surprising.
Because if you think about it.
You taking up for this guy?
No no no I'm saying the
step one, the first step
is I don't think that
that's where he went wrong.
Because what I'll say is,
I don't have this experience
because I've only had sex with one woman
and we've never broken up.
But if like my wife goes out of town,
or I go out of town and
you get back together.
Sometimes that first reunion,
you don't last as long because
you're super excited right?
Yeah.
And so if you've broken up
with somebody and you
haven't had sex in awhile,
and you hadn't done the
old "Something About Mary"
when you kind of get
one out of the chamber
before you get together
which I do recommend.
If you haven't done that,
you might only last 30 seconds
but in that moment after you,
this is where post-nut clarity
really comes into play.
If you have lasted 30
seconds and you're like,
I think, I would be like,
"Oh I'm sorry you're just so hot."
Or something like that you know?
Yep.
And then if I had to fart,
I wouldn't because I, at least at this age
I still cannot fart when I
don't want to most of the time.
Not everybody can.
And I don't play Diablo.
I didn't play Diablo I so.
Nope.
That, I just can't.
At that point, I just can't relate at all.
But I feel like the
first step was you know,
how you responded after that first slipup
is where he started going wrong.
After Jenna's comeback,
I got nothing to add.
That was amazing.
I think it just all feels.
I feel like that great.
Very intentional.
He went in, knowing it was gonna be short.
He was gonna do
something gross.
Yeah.
And then he was gonna ask about
some video game.
Yeah I'm not a fan
of this person.
No, no no.
Yeah yeah yeah.
I think it's good
they broke up.
Wow.
We can have one last voicemail here.
No.
Ope that's not it.
Right down there.
Hi Rhett and Link.
I have a very funny story
in response to your Sextember
tweet about my poor friend
when we were babies in college.
We weren't literal babies but
we were very young people.
18 or 19 and she had .
Sorry, it's so funny.
Never given a blowjob before
and she had started dating this guy
and they were about to go all the way
and she was telling me all about
and how she wanted to try to
give him a blowjob that night
and so the next day I
asked her how it went.
And she was like,
"I don't know, it was kind of weird.
"I don't think that he was super into it."
And I was very confused.
I said, "What was he not
into, what did you do?"
Apparently my poor, sweet friend
took the name blowjob very literally
and so she you know, went down there
and just was blowing
cold air on his genitals.
For a solid two or three minutes
before he finally was like,
"Yeah no, we're not doing that any more.
"Okay, we're gonna go do other things."
And my poor, sweet angel friend
was horrified when I told her what that,
what actually a blowjob entailed.
So it was pretty funny.
This is why sex education is important.
Yeah.
Everybody and that's all
I have to say, bye.
That's why I call it a suckjob.
You know?
You just, let's get it.
Let's just say what it is.
Oh my gosh.
Just, I mean was it?
Makes a good story.
Was there a distance there?
Like blowing from a distance?
I feel like.
Total like,
a total get on it and then blow it up
like an inflatable tube.
Yeah.
If I was horny enough.
For your pool.
And I hadn't had sex in long enough,
I feel like you might be
able to get me with just air.
You know what I'm saying?
If it was like a pneumatic thing?
That would be a fun precursor
but if you're latching
on and then you're just,
you're blowing.
I mean is it?
There was no latching.
Will that go to the urethra?
Will that go up to the bladder?
Oh you're saying if.
Can the bladder explode?
If you blow it, that
wasn't what was happening
in this scenario.
This was
blowing from a distance.
Like actually blowing up
a balloon.
You don't want to do that.
Yeah, that can cause a lot of issues.
I totally thought that.
I am in that poor girl's boat.
I 100%.
This was you?
Yeah 100% thought that a blowjob
meant you blow on a penis.
From a distance?
From a distance.
But you don't have to answer this question
if you don't want to.
So I understand her
being mortified.
But did you, did you
have a similar experience
or do you just, this was
a thought that you had?
I had a similar experience.
You don't have to answer it Jenna,
you don't have to answer it.
She already did.
She had a similar experience.
It's okay.
I've done a lot of embarrassing
things, we're good.
We're good.
But yeah I, yeah.
I blew on my boyfriend's penis
and I thought that's what a blowjob was.
And then how did that, then what?
It was very awkward.
Thank.
We moved on quickly to something else.
Right, yeah yeah yeah.
Okay, okay.
And then I learned later.
Later.
That that's incorrect.
He probably just thought
you were creative.
Like oh wow.
I was creative.
We're just trying out.
Literal.
She's kind of different.
Something new and fun.
She's got a different
take on things.
Blowing around the area.
I think I blew on his
balls at one point too.
Yeah right.
Okay Jenna.
Yeah yeah yeah.
I mean.
You can blow on anything you want to.
So you can blow.
Yeah.
Yeah yeah yeah yeah.
I can blow, yeah.
Yeah yeah.
It's like yeah I've got breath.
I've seen a birthday cake before.
I'm mortified, yeah yeah.
I know what to do here.
Wow, wow wow wow.
Wow wow wow wow.
Sorry to my Jimbo.
Oh God.
Okay.
But she is not alone.
That.
Yeah yeah yeah.
That woman is not alone, been there.
This concludes our.
Well listen.
Our Sextember.
I mean the fact that
this was a story from this woman
and then you had the same experience,
I mean this is not an uncommon thing.
Why is it called a blowjob?
Why even call it that?
Like?
I don't know, it's a misnomer.
Really, I just don't know.
I know.
I just don't know why.
Yeah.
I can't, I can't.
Of all the words
that it could've been, that's
the phrase that won out.
Right.
I don't know why.
There's a lot of sex terms
that don't make sense.
Yeah.
But this one is one
that just feels like a real, real miss.
I mean fellatio is just
a really great name.
That's just a technical term.
I don't know why it would
ever be called a blowjob.
I guess because it's like wow this is my,
I'm, it's explosive.
I don't know.
I think you're making a,
your mouth looks like
you might be blowing.
Maybe the first time someone
saw somebody doing it,
it was like, "Ah I think
she might be blowing
"on his dick."
I mean I'm not the one there.
Right, this is a third party
analysis.
It was like it was a doctor
watching a video.
It was like, she is now
blowing on his penis.
He seems to enjoy it, blowjob.
She looks like she's working, blowjob.
Yeah.
Yep.
Why is it a job?
Right.
Exactly.
Because no one wants to do it.
Right.
Right, right.
That's the other part
I don't like about it.
Yeah yeah, yeah.
It should be a suck favor.
A lick fantasy.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like yeah.
It's not just suck, you don't
wanna suck too hard either.
I don't want to call it a suck favor.
Call it a.
It's like a Tootsie Pop.
How many licks does it take?
To get to the.
But if you have to, I mean yeah.
But don't bite, yeah.
I don't know.
Gently, gently.
What's a word for sucking on something
with an intention to lick on it?
Not just to suck on it.
I think there's probably
a German word for it.
I think, what about
more of a sloppy savor?
Savory.
I don't know.
We know, we all know now.
I think we'll just go with blowjob.
Let's go with blowjob.
We'll go with blowjob
and just take the funny
stories as they come.
Wow, I am, I am exhausted.
I am totally just, I don't
have a recommendation.
Well, we don't have to
Because we talked to two
incredibly insightful doctors.
Yeah.
Who have
incredible resources.
We talked about sex
with Emily, the podcast.
Their books.
Follow them, go for it.
That's the.
Dr. Emily Nagoski's book,
"Come As You Are", which we've
already rec'd one time and
her book that's coming out.
Let's do it again.
So just, you know what?
Check out their resources.
We have to tell you multiple times.
You have to hear something.
You have to hear the Gospel 19 times
before you make a decision Link.
So you're hearing this rec multiple times.
Next week we're going to
be having a special listening party
for a very special, is that it?
Yeah.
Is that it?
That is what we're doing next right?
Yeah yeah yeah.
A special listening party
for a special, I can't talk anymore.
I told you.
I am just, I am burnt to a sexual crisp.
Yeah, so this coming week.
For a special project.
This coming week, a couple
of things will happen.
Actually, when you're hearing this,
my new single "Give A Damn"
just came out this past Friday.
If you're listening to "Ear
Biscuits" when it comes out
and then on the 23rd, the
whole album will come out
and we're gonna listen
to the entire thing.
Yes.
Right here.
And hear Link's analysis of it.
Yeah it's like a,
it'll be a little listening party for us.
Come next week.
In the meantime, #EarBiscuits.
Well I just will say.
What, say it.
You'll get more out of next week's podcast
if you listen to the full album.
Beforehand.
So James and the Shame.
Yeah.
Good point.
Human Overboard, 11 songs.
It's out there.
It takes you less
than 45 minutes or so
to listen to the whole thing
and then we'll talk about it next week.
In the meantime, we do want
to hear your responses.
#EarBiscuits
and 1-888-EARPOD1.
One.
Talk it to me.
Hi Rhett and Link it's Amanda.
I love listening to
everything you guys do.
Even as a lesbian woman
having sex with only her wife.
Sextember is something we both enjoy
and gives us a lot of new information
that sometimes we might want to try.
So thank you so much for doing all that
and thank you Jenna for
adding a female body
into the dimension there.
Hi Rhett and Link, this is Trang.
Longtime listener, first time
"Ear Biscuits" participant.
You guys mentioned that
nobody has ever gotten sick
from blue balls before and I
just wanted to let you know
that my boyfriend did
make a visit to the ER
for having what I like to call blue balls.
Since he had free fluid in his balls
that were really painful
and he just rested for a couple days.
Hey my name's Jake.
I'm from Philadelphia and I
just wanted to thank you both,
give some appreciation
for mentioning asexuality
in the latest episode of Sextember.
I'm asexual and it's something
that you don't hear about, ever.
Really the only reason it took
me a long time to figure out
is because you don't hear about it.
So just even a small mention
like that means a great deal
and for you guys to treat
it very legitimately
and not like there's
something wrong with a person
or like it's a medical issue is,
is, feels great.
Hey guys, this is Summer
and I just need to thank
you all for Sextember.
It has been something that
I've been listening to
with my husband and because of it,
my husband and I have had
the best sex of our lives.
We were already open and
talked about sex before
but it's just created
even more conversation
and I really think that you,
you guys need to be thanked for it
and so thanks again for Sextember.
Love you guys, can't wait to
listen to the next episode.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits"
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.